[Applause]
what's matthew mcconaughey up to is he
trying to podcast or something he's
i think he wants to get into politics
yeah there's something he's pivotal he's
doing did he say he's gonna try to run
for something
he's doing politics i knew there's
something you might try to run for texas
governor
that's what it was a brilliant way to
get votes in texas
to call out yeah and to say i'm he says
i'm aggressively centrist that's the
term he uses
and then he called out you guys all know
he called out basically hollywood
liberals
who are making fun of republicans who
won't accept the election results yeah
and he's like i saw
you this exact person liberal person do
this
when trump won now all of a sudden uh
republicans are doing it and they're
idiots and you're so condescending and
arrogant about it holy [ __ ] we've been
saying to be honest
right but it's also kind of nice to
watch a hollywood elite
call out hollywood elites you know what
i mean and it's like a good sign that
this is all kind of like all right this
this thing we're calling it out
yeah he's making a move man i don't know
what's gonna happen hollywood bro
like i think that [ __ ] it's moving
austin buddy
yeah low-key elon musk is coming yo yo
a lot a lot of people come let me just
silicon valley on its way
goldman is moving to where duff florida
bro they're all moving to the red states
goldman goldman sachs not not sorry
goldman sachs that's
just like california's gdp is always so
high or whatever
i don't think it's about to plummet i
think slowly
like big dogs are just gonna keep moving
why would you pay those taxes
and austin is the perfect place because
they have mostly liberal ideals
but you don't pay taxes yeah it's
everything they want do you think that
shifts the
like the political paradigm in those
places you see everyone leaving they go
ah we gotta pull this [ __ ] back
and then all of a sudden in like
california new york people are starting
to go
well [ __ ] i guess we got to pull
ourselves up by our bootstraps
nobody's bailing us out i guess we got
to figure it out ourselves
what if there's this massive flip that's
what i'm saying
everyone wants to live in republican
states
nobody does or you know everyone does
everybody does yeah and then all
what i'm saying is california gonna turn
yeah yeah
that is interesting if you're like a if
you're like a california
like republican like nominee or whatever
yeah i feel like this is your best
chance
you know what i mean like to go for it
if you're running for senate or
something in california and you're
republican you're like
yo i'm not what's ruined it was moving
everyone out like
there's something that happened in
within this election i think people have
spoken about this before but like trump
lost
but trump policy
didn't yeah a lot of people became
open-minded about
conservativism and
i think that this was the first time
that it all sudden became relatable
trump was so polarizing trump was so
divisive that like they weren't they
were kind of like grossed out by trump
the figure
but i think a lot of liberals were just
exhausted by like the nancy pelosi's of
the world and these like
full-life politicians that just
absolutely suck and they're just
mucking about with this system it seems
like they're kind of like using it for
their own
personal benefit or party benefit rather
and i think they can't became a little
disenfranchised with the left man and i
would not be surprised if you see
in the next few like uh what is called
the midterm elections i believe it's
called
i would not be surprised if you see
people start leaning right man
leaning right especially now the
president isn't right so there's gonna
be a correction
because of that right there's going to
be this like reaction
they didn't get their way so they're
going to lean super hard and try to
flynn is an indication of that that
he's kind of a moderate i mean he's much
more of a lifetime politician but he's
kind of a moderate democrat that's the
thing but it's a rejection
of the bernie [ __ ] yeah right like and
i'm [ __ ] with bernie but
it's a rejection of like the aocs it's a
rejection of the squad like even
democrats were like nah this is not the
thing that we like
i think we think democrats are just new
york and just la
and democrats are also the ones that get
you elected they're in the middle of the
country and the middle of the country
is only so left-wing they're not coastal
where it's like yeah aoc is everything
that's perfect she's perfect
they're like nah she's a little crazy
but i generally agree with the left more
than the right
yeah that's a middle america democrat
joe biden
hey i'm not i'm not here trying to
[ __ ] defund the police completely or
whatever i just want police to be a
little better and that's how middle
america feels regardless of how we feel
that's how i think a lot of middle
america feels